okay in this lesson we're going to talk
about the very important slope-intercept
form so this is something you definitely
want to understand for the s80 and let's
get into this lesson so first of all
what slope-intercept form is it's a form
of the equation of the line and it's
often written as y equals MX plus B the
M which is the number that comes to the
left or in front of the x that's the
slope and the bee that's the constant
that's just the number of your by itself
that's the y-intercept but when it comes
to word problems okay our story problems
the M or the slope you can think of that
as the rate okay so the rate of change
how fast something is increasing or how
fast something is decreasing it's the
rate of change the B that's the
y-intercept but it again and a word
problem or story problem this is really
like the initial condition or the
starting amount okay now when it comes
to graphing lines and slope intercept
form you can see the wise by itself y
equals 3x plus 1 you can start over here
at the initial condition or the
y-intercept which is one and you can see
it has a slope of 3 which is like 3 over
1 so the slope is the rise over run so
from here we're going to go rise three
and run once you're going up 3 over 1
and that's how you can you know get the
graph of your line let's get into three
examples so you can see how these
problems could appear potentially on the
s80 and so you'll be ready to solve
those kinds of problems so the first one
it says John leaves home and heads to
school at the rate of two miles per hour
his distance from the school is given by
the equation D equals 8 minus 2h what
does the eight represent okay this right
here is that the rate at which John went
to school is it how far John's house is
from school or is it how long it takes
John to get to school so go ahead and
pause the video see if you can solve
this one on your own and we'll go
through it together so the first thing
to recognize is that doesn't let's look
a lot like y equals MX plus B the only
difference is is seed is eight they put
here instead of over here at the end but
let's just rewrite it so this is really
like y equals a negative two x plus 8
i'm just writing it in the
slope-intercept form
but we know that this constant this
eight is the y-intercept but in a word
problem it's like the initial condition
it's a starting amount the M is the
slope that's the rate so in this
particular problem the eight means that
you know John is eight miles from school
and he's narrowing his distance or
decreasing his distance at the rate of
two miles per hour so the negative 2
means is decreasing so basically in this
problem the eight is how far John's
Health is from school initially right
and he's getting there or decreasing
that distance at two miles per hour so
these are going to be the best buy an
answer for this one okay example number
two it says what is the equation of the
line so here they're just giving us a
line and they just want us to find the
equation in slope-intercept form y
equals MX plus B what do you think go
ahead and pause the video see if you can
solve this one on your own so the thing
that I notice here is that the
y-intercept is to sobe is going to be
too and I notice that the slope is the
rise over the run so it's going up to
and right three so that's going to be a
slope of two thirds so the equation of
the line is going to be y equals
two-thirds X plus 2 ok so that's just
writing the equation of line now the
third example it says that Duty loses a
pound per week and y represents beauties
weight after w weeks okay and they give
us this equation here y equals negative
1 w + 10 3 what is judy's initial weight
before starting her diet well again you
can see that this is in that form y
equals MX plus B the B is the initial
condition so she originally was a
hundred and three pounds and she's
losing one pound per week that's the
slope that's the rate of change that's
the number in front of the variable here
that's the negative one so understanding
how to work with slope intercept form
the y equals MX plus B form definitely
sometimes they are going to test you on
when you take the essay to review this
lesson if you need to otherwise i'll see
you in the next lesson